الى مواقع التواصل وقضيه شغلتها خلال
الساعات الماضيه تحت اكثر من وسم منها
اعدام عمار مفلح واعدام حواره وكلنا عمار
عمات مواقع التواصل في فلسطين وبلدان
عربيه اخرى مشاعر الغضب والصدمه والتمديد
بعد حادثه قتل جنديا اسرائيلي شاب فلسطيني
حاول مقاومه اعتقاله في بلده حواره جنوب
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه ما الذي حدث
بالضبط في بلده حواره في الضفه الغربيه
مقطع فيديو يظهر لحظه قيام الجمهوريه
الاسرائيلي باعدام الشهيد عمار مفلح من
المسافات السفر كما وصفوها كما يظهر
الفيديو عدم حمل الشهيد عمار لاي سلاح على
عكس ماء زعمت وسائل واعلام اسرائيليه بان
شاب حاول تنفيذ عمليه الطعن على حاجز
حواره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن التفاعلات الكثيره على مواقع التواصل
في تويتر وفيسبوك اخرى رضوان الاخرس كتب
على تويتر قتله السارقون الغاصبون على
ارضه وبين اهله
هو من اصعب المشاهد التي رايتها في حياتي
هذا هو الشهيد الفلسطيني
لهم عائله ومحبون وكان لهم امال واحلام
ابو المجد كتابه
بوجه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكتب جهاد هذه
هي اسرائيل وهذا هو ارهابها اعدام الشهيد
مراه العالم جريمه بشعه